يشتد سباق الانتخابات العامه التركيه
وتشتد معه حمى الاستقطابات السياسيه فتظهر
تحالفات سياسيه غير تقليديه واحيانا غير
متجانسه كما فعل اردوغان الذي طرح قائمه
اسماء مختلفه جذريا عن تحالفاته السياسيه
اردوغان الساعي الى تامين اغلبيه البرلمان
بالتوازي مع سعيه لفتره رئاسيه جديده اتجه
الى ترشيح اسماء غير اعتياديه ابرز
الاسماء التي نتحدث عنها هو لاعب كره
القدم التركيه الالمانيه المعتزل حديثا
مسعود اوزيل وهي نقله نوعيه للاعب السابق
من الملاعب للسياسه من اوزيل الى سيده
سرباش عارضه الازياء وملكه الجمال السابقه
رشحت لمقعد عن ولايه ايدن ووصلت قبل عامين
لعضويه اعلى هيئه في حزب العداله والتنميه
وهي هيئه القرار والتنفيذ المركزي
امور عده تشهدها هذه الانتخابات للمره
الاولى منها طرح اصغر مرشحه عن المنطقه
الاولى لولايه ازمير بتاريخ الانتخابات
تدعى نيسا ابتكن ذات 18 عاما يعرفها
الاتراك في اوساطهم بالمراهقه الفاتنه رغم
انها لا تزال طالبه جامعيه لكن قوتها تاتي
من كونها ابنه احد مؤسسي حزب العداله
والتنميه اسلحه اردوغان في المعركه
الانتخابيه تتنوع من الفن والرياضه
والتمثيل لكن ابرزها الصحفيون رغم ان عهد
الرئيس التركي اتهم بالكثير من عمليات
الحبس وتكميم الافواه
استقطاب قد يوحي بقلق اردوغان ازاء
مستقبله السياسي بطرحه اسماء شعبويه قادره
على جذب شرائح متعدده من الاتراك الى صفه
في مواجهه منافسه المعارض كمال كلجد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات